bom dia a todos obrigado por terem vindo
embora não tenha vindo por minha causa
porque eu sei que ninguém conhece meu
pai que você está a pensar que parece e
eles podem testar para você pergunta é e
eu sou uma empresa grande e neste
momento eu sou parece que temos que
assumir aquilo que somos e embora já
tenha feito muita coisa é neste momento
a trabalhar como peça eu fiz uma cábula
e principalmente o respeito que temos
que ter com o público porque vocês
vieram cá pra provar alguma coisa
interessante e eu tentei encontrar umas
coisas interessantes implantar aqui só
fazer palhaçadas
eis precisou fazer uma tatuagem do
sentido o papel da empresa
a responsabilidade é muito difícil pra
mim embora eu fazia teatro e e nós só
temos assistido a explosã o cinema e nós
quando temos uma personagem é muito mais
fácil quando estamos nós de que nos
sentimos mais mais luz esteja nessa aula
não tenho casa aqui quero quero mesmo é
tentar criar aqui uma personagem que eu
diga quem eu sou
é um então é andré
fiz alguns apontamentos porque realmente
foi convidado em cima da hora não vou
dizer o quão em cima da hora foi
convidado para não envergonhar a
organização é então tive apenas a
segurança contará com algumas coisas
é então é o que o que eu posso que
algumas pessoas disseram foi é falar e 6
no centro próprio e falando do teu
percurso é o meu percurso foi nesse caso
eu sair é nosso de teatro os pais mas a
ironia do destino fez um trabalhar em
teatro e
e eu sentia que tinha em design foi paga
pelo ordenado que eu tenho quatro foi
irônico mas a vida é mesmo assim e
acabamos por fazer o curso que temos que
fazer
e olhem pro meu percurso é é aquilo que
caracteriza mais fazendo assim uma
retrospectiva é que o que eu fiz foi
infeliz vi e superar isso pode ser a
coisa mais importante pra vocês ganham
sábados manhã houve aqui alguém é o joão
vi que era uma pessoa muito feliz
depois de testar tanto tempo neste
início de agosto ao lado né
expresse um alvo a abater e um depois
tentar aqui temos que ganhar e agora vai
conseguir atuar mais ainda mesmo tempo
mas é o que caracteriza realmente o meu
percurso reuters influência naquilo que
fiz é então um dia que eu descobri essa
funcionária foi na criatividade é
trabalhei em design em teatro tv e
cinema e animação em de aulas e tentei
sempre que o o trabalho que eu faço é
diferente
às vezes o ser diferente faz correr mal
era esquemas como joão diz o sucesso
implica o risco risco às vezes implica
as coisas correrem mal e tentei sempre
que o fazer diferente mas fazer
diferente diferente pessoas também
reconheçam porque se faça um diferencial
pra mim trabalhar com com o meu ex
artista e ea também precisa ser público
somente o teatro eo teatro não é tão mal
apoiado que realmente tem que as pessoas
têm que perceber aquilo que a gente faz
e tem que compreender tempo que tem que
ser uma partida muito realmente um dia
ter alguma coisa pra dizer o mundo né
é mas imaginei que fosse acontecer
quando eu fosse mais velhinho já tem sua
barba e fala ah se tivesse alguma coisa
diz ele
entretanto convidado para dar aulas e é
isso obrigados a pagar para ter alguma
coisa a dizer é e então ele começou e só
então realizar e essa responsabilidade
tenho uma filha e também é com 9 anos
também naquela idade do que saber tudo
então uma responsabilidade maior e hoje
tenho aqui pessoas que não conhecem o
governo falar de mim e e eu vou tentar
falar com vocês com creme com seus
filhos com piada mas não funcionou
é é a criatividade é eu li o título é
esta é esse discurso de criatividade
traz felicidade
vou tentar arranjar um tempo pensou
nisso e acho que se eu voltar a estudar
se eu teria coragem de voltar a estudar
é eu não tenho pensado muito sobre isto
e é andré que criatividade seja onde for
só que na publicidade por exemplo é o da
credibilidade e deprimida é pensar em
todos estão a pensar num momento
criativo
vamos parar aqui a criatividade é sempre
fruto de um processo de de desconstrução
de descontextualização o inter
relacionamento ou de administrar o
cinismo da abstração é essas obras caras
não dá um crédito é então tentar
explicar o que acontece e pensem num
exemplo voz que vocês aquela publicidade
mesmo dinheiro
o processo de construção é um processo
criativo que é uma coisa construída é
algo que só lhe reconhecem seja um
edifício seja um caminho seja um
pensamento uma coisa tá bem construída
não surpreende ninguém me não é criativo
embora seja aceita
e a gente quer um prédio em construção
que mas chegaram criativos construa
depois de ter os elementos todos
construídos já pode construí-lo se possa
surpreender
por isso normalmente é uma equipa
criativa é sempre ótimo que haja alguém
muito muito assertivo pensa com os pés
na terra e depois uma outra pessoa é que
pensa com a cabeça na lua para um
projetar e construir outras construir o
ideal é que a pessoa tenha essa
capacidade de fazer é então este é o
processo de desconstrução o processo de
internacionalização
então aos contextos missão é assim diz
pensarmos que o que é é a criatividade a
surpresa surge em momentos que não
surpreendem porque estão estão fora do
sítio
não é é a minha mãe é ela será formada
mas ela todas todos os meses ela usava
os os móveis da casa e quando chegava
ficava esperando mulher que não sabia
que estava nada e isto é um ato criativo
dela é criatividade e realmente este
processo e quando nós teatro por exemplo
usamos um um objeto que possa significar
outro estamos a descontextualizar 1 e o
público a acompanhar essa
contextualização e estamos a ser
criativos nós eo público que o teatro é
enfrentar esse encontro é a tração é é
um movimento muito criativa a gente vê
um quadro abstrato em um picasso e
embora não não podemos não perceber
realmente mas o processo criativo não
não foi um segundo eu a primeira vez que
vi foi o prazo em madri e fiquei super
surpreendido quando quando vi um quadro
e pois uma sala com 54 foram processo
será que eu vou te contar uma história
que lembra a irmã tem que aprender ser
interessante é perceber ele o processo
criativo é edson zoom é que viseu é com
o match.com tac apresentar licença voz é
que eu ganhei do palmar
nós criamos um espetáculo que eram os
inspetores da bicharada e os inspetores
da virada é um espetáculo que foi
inspirado num livro e que nós criamos a
nossa opção descontextualizadas e
desconstruindo o livro é a história do
tempo é que era a história de nós
queremos explicar que cada pessoa pode
ver a sua maneira o mundo então é contar
a história 3 animaizinhos da floresta
que manhã para a escola e quando
chegavam à escola na teoria tinham visto
um animal que nunca tinham nunca tinha
visto e viram o animal em cima de uma
pedra do sol e chegaram todos sobre um
animal e assim chegou outro animal sobre
seu irmão era uma pessoa calma e nem
faça um desânimo
então o corpo foi o primeiro animal é
ver um outro animal e o corpo ea voar e
vive lá embaixo poço em cima de marco e
viu o animal em cima da pedra e com os
reflexos dos alunos dos brilhos de cor
pintou o impressionou mais de pintar o
estilo impressionista
estamos falando assim explicar o
impressionismo movimento anos 50 do
século passado
a inscrição impressionismo e é isto era
o corvo é pinto que se impressionou ele
impressionou se com os vídeos com as
cores do daquele animal é é leve pessoa
correr e nem peru nem par ou vilões e
claro com sua altura pintar não parou em
tudo o que eu gostava então é ter que
substituir os trios daquilo que
realmente não viu e pintou que o preço
for mais essencial logo pintou o estilo
mais abstrato
o processo da extração estejam limpar a
e ficar com
o essencial para o nível é por último o
último animal foi até o país no topo
ainda viu um azul
acho que eu vou um buraco do outro
indivíduo outros como freqüentar gostou
do que viu e pintos o rio é fácil todo
seu estilo cubista pintou a cara vista
do marido junto a este espetáculo foi um
dia depois de o avião havia 11 o
workshop foi humilde poderem pintar
também a sua maneira de pensar em si e e
em que nós queríamos transmitir este
cada um pode ver a sua maneira e extraí
street se impressionar se e captar e
transmitir osasuna é um ato criativo é é
um processo que é fundamental para o
proselitismo mas também para os
cientistas e também para as crianças
e estes três grupos de pessoas são as
pessoas que nós tenhamos mais enviar né
no dia a dia e vimos constantemente
nesta v tentar ver o mundo dessa forma
eu vou dar dois exemplos de coisas que
eu acho que são extraordinárias é como
como ato criativo quem já é pai é só ter
um filho e uma criação fantástica e não
se comparam um filho com uma peça de
teatro com quadro obviamente mas mas é
uma criação é uma criação e pra quem tem
um público e criar um produto é que quer
defendeu hoje consigo viver da minha
arte dos meus espetáculos é uma palhaça
é e e tem uma grande responsabilidade
com que minha filha eu quero que ela
seja ela funciona que ela se enquadre
não quer que ela seja uma final do
returno
é que quero que ela se enquadre que ela
funciona mas que ela seja feliz e siga
em frente e quero acrescentar alguma
coisa ao mundo e é isso que quatro
criativo é fácil seja do artista seja o
cientista é por isso que nós criamos é
esse para mim os planos máximos da
criação e quem tem filhos compreende
isto quem é um flash mínimo mas
igualmente importante que em tudo começa
eu olhar a forma como se olha as coisas
quantos de nós adultos deixamos de olhar
para as formas que não vejo nos inspiram
para parar é o consumo de uma flor da
somos capazes de pagar um dia tira
adversários virgins mas criar não
reparamos que nosso nossa senhora que o
vaso que a gente plantou temas sobre tem
cheiro tem uma forma de nos adaptar a
ela
então acho que dá sim não tem a certeza
podem não acreditar mas eu tenho certeza
é é criticar a sociedade da forma como
nós vemos as coisas e uma pessoa
criativa é uma pessoa feliz porque é uma
pessoa que que não aceita nada como nada
é uma pessoa que olha e contempla nós
hoje não há tempo para contemplar nada e
falta um minuto
então vamos dar uma palhaça pois assim
tava tanto gozo fazer porque ser palhaço
é assumir que se encaram as situações
com a simplicidade uma criança melhor
característica de um palhaço não é
estabilidade sabia fazer aquilo que eu
não sou assim dada por veloso
embora você caro já encenado há muitos
anos foi há 20 anos que disse não fazer
malabarismo mas eu nunca pratiquei muito
e características de um palhaço eu olhar
certamente você já já foram molhados por
um bebê que não fala mas que olha nós
até chegamos em cruzados porque está
mesmo olhar e e eu te olhar porque
precisa
construir e desconstruir os comentários
de paixão e o controle da situação
militar e esse olhar essa simplicidade é
o que traz é a criatividade
um palhaço ver tudo de forma simples ver
tudo de forma nova original e por isso é
que é feliz não é porque é tonto época
no chão e não não é por aí
é humor é então aquele ingrediente que
essa já não aprovou a troca as pessoas
têm medo de palhaço é natural
não há nada que nós mais do que uma
pessoa feliz e sou feliz e é capaz de
tudo e é capaz de derrubar as barreiras
da conexão as barreiras das mais caras
que nós criamos
embora o processo seja o mais grave e
consequemente mesmo absurdo desmascarada
e flamengo nunca pode tudo é capaz de
vir e e dever desta postura que o time
tem muito correta ela vai casar comigo e
então só tem mesmo o palhaço é natural
eu também eu também tinha quando não era
feliz já que estamos a falar de
felicidade é terminar com com isso não
podia virar estes deixar de dizer que
ocupa no mundo eu quero ter mais filhos
e quero que meus filhos vivam no mundo
trás e temos que salvar e e não é não é
deixar de poluir
vamos deixar de salvar o mundo não é é
reduzir as emissões de gases tóxicos
isso é o que deve ser mas se formos a
origem é muito mais rápido
se nós formos a origem todo tudo mal
estamos a fazer o planeta deve ser uma
coisa o nosso conceito de felicidade
porque as coisas que nos fazem felizes
são coisas que destrói o mundo e se nós
pensarmos nisto e sempre mais uma
decisão pensarmos isto faz com que
realmente dá gozo comprar estoques casar
com minha mãe comprou e 25 cêntimos numa
loja solidária
eu acho que quebrei o braço cubano
é eu acho que é por aí é só vamos o
planeta se mudarmos o nosso conceito
cidade vocês estão aqui todos são
pessoas interessadas incluem não vou
explicar isso pensa sobre isto e sejam
criativos e sejam felizes
[Aplausos]